– Lisa, halt dich doch einfach mal da raus!
Das geht dich überhaupt nichts an!
– Ich halte mich bestimmt nicht raus,
wenn du so verantwortungslos bist.
– Ach! Aber wenn es darum geht, mich zu
Untersuchungen zu begleiten,
dann hältst du dich gerne raus.
Du hast gesagt, du hilfst mir.
– Nina, ich habe eine Arbeit.
Ich habe keine Zeit.
– Stell dir vor, es gibt andere Menschen,
die haben auch Berufe.
Die gehen arbeiten und haben trotzdem Zeit.
Und manche haben sogar Kinder.
– Ja, und manche Menschen passen
beim Sex besser auf,
damit sie ihre Zeit eben nicht beim
Frauenarzt verbringen müssen.
Entschuldigung, das war scheiße!
– Nina … Nina, du ...
bist ... bist schwanger?
– Ja.
– Ja, dann herzlichen Glückwunsch!
– Ich kann jetzt kein Kind kriegen.
– Nina …
– Weißt du, was?
Dario hat mich verlassen!
– Was?
– Ja! Uh! Wahnsinn, wie du dich
für mein Leben interessierst.
– Was bedeutet „schwanger“?